[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hello.
In this video, I'm going to
be talking about webR 0.2.0,
and, in particular, R
packages for WebAssembly.
So webR supports
loading R packages.
They have to first be available
on the virtual file system.
But once they're there,
they can be loaded.
So there's a few ways to
ensure that those packages are there.
They can be manually copied
to the virtual file system
location, /usr/lib/R/library.
But there's also a
helper function provided by webR
that will install R packages
to that location for you.
This helper function also
is connected to a binary
repository that contains
R packages built
for WebAssembly.
So if you ask for a package
that exists in that repository,
it will go and download
it, extract the files,
and put them on the virtual
file system for you.
There is
issues when it comes to
converting R packages
to run on WebAssembly.
The biggest issue is probably
that R packages with compiled
code need to have that code
recompiled so that it can run
under WebAssembly.
And that includes not only the
code that exists inside an R
package but also any system
libraries that that code
depends on. So if you have some
C code in an R package that uses
libxml2, for example,
to pass some XML files,
that system library,
that XML system library,
will also have to be
converted into WebAssembly and provided
so that that package
can run under webR.
So we've done some
work in webR 0.2.0
to increase the number of system
libraries available for use with webR.
And the way we do this
is that we have certain recipes that
exist in the webR source
repository. And if you ask for
these packages to be built,
there's a command you can
run to build them all.
It will go away and build
all these packages one by one
for WebAssembly.
And once those packages
are built for WebAssembly,
R packages can be
linked to use them
to include that code
in those R packages.
So there's a selection
of new libraries here.
There's various graphics
libraries that are used in the
previous videos when I talked
about the cairo bitmap graphics.
So there's
text rendering and
graphics libraries.
There's some various
utility libraries. There's sqlite3
for databases.
And there's also some
geospatial and computational
geometry packages, like
geos, gdal, and proj.
And they are used to
enable some extra geospatial packages
in the latest version of webR.
By including these
system libraries,
we've been able to
expand the number of R
packages that are
supported by webR.
And those R packages are
hosted on a binary repository
at that URL there.
And this is the
repository that's automatically used by
the webR install command if you do
ask for an R package in webR.
So in the previous release,
by the end of that
release cycle,
we had about 219 packages
available for use.
Now we have more.
We have 10,324,
which is about 51% of CRAN.
And that's how many packages are
available in that binary repo now.
I should say that we
haven't tested all of these packages.
What available here means is that
a package is able to be
compiled by the
Emscripten compiler for WebAssembly.
So that R package
can be compiled
as well as all the packages
that it depends on.
So if an R package depends
on some other R package, if it's
available in webR,
it means that all of
that dependency chain has been
resolved and all of those
packages have been compiled for WebAssembly.
So
because there are quite a
few packages available now,
you can use built-in R tools
to list those packages.
I think the function is
available.packages to list all
of those. But it might
be a bit tricky to
run through all that data,
particularly if you just want to know
if a single package works or not.
So one of the things we've
done is we've updated the repository
so that the index page--
if you were to visit that
repository in a web browser,
the index page that you
see after a loading period looks
like this. And it tells
you how many packages are available,
and it gives you a list
that you can search through.
So, for example, if you wanted
to know if ggplot is available,
you could just type ggplot2 in the
box there. And you can see, OK, package
ggplot2 is available and all
of its dependencies are also
available. So I can use
that package in webR.
So this is a really nice
useful little tool to just see which
packages are now
available for use in webR.
Some examples of packages
that are now available. tidyverse
and tidymodels are
both available.
So if I run that code,
it will go and download those packages.
There they are.
Not all of the
tidyverse packages are available,
I should admit. There are some
that can't easily be used in
WebAssembly, because they need to
connect to the network, and
direct network access is one
of the things that's restricted in
the WebAssembly environment.
But the core tidyverse packages
are there and can be attached.
And the same with tidymodels.
The tidymodels packages are available
and they can all be
attached. So you can run
your tidymodels code in webR.
And you can run your
core tidyverse code in webR.
Geospatial packages are
available. So, in particular,
that includes the sf
package for simple features.
So if I run this
piece of code again,
it will go and download
those packages and then run
this small piece of code that's going
to plot a map for us projected
onto a certain type
of map projection.
So there's some computational
geometry going on there.
And then all of those
state lines are plotted there with
ggplot here in this example.
So there are various
geospatial data packages
available now to use in webR.
And there's also
database packages.
So here is an example of
the DBI package being used with the
RSQLite package.
Database systems
on a server somewhere connected
over the network won't work,
again because network
connections are one of the
things in WebAssembly
that's restricted.
But in-memory databases, like
SQLite, is available. So here's
an example that takes some data
and puts it into an SQLite database.
And then we have some SQL code
here that we can use to query
that data. So if you're a
user who prefers to use R
with DBI to run SQL code,
you can do that.
So you can change that code. Well,
maybe I can--
there we go.
You can change the code and
get immediate results in webR.
You can see I'm not a SQL
programmer, as you can see by
that previous example.
But it does work.
You're able to run your
SQL code directly there. Again,
SQLite is probably the only
database that is well supported here,
just because many other
databases will require network connections.
And, finally,
the last thing I want to
talk about with R packages is Shiny
and httpuv,
which is one of the
support packages that Shiny uses.
So the httpuv package,
again, is based on
network connections.
It's a server that can
listen for httpuv--
sorry--
HTTP
and WebSocket traffic, and
then respond to those requests.
So a package shim has
been created for webR,
which is available
on the on the r-wasm
organization if you want to
read the source code for that.
And what that is is it's a
package that acts like httpuv
but is re-implemented to be
used with webR. And, in particular,
what it's doing is
taking advantage of a JavaScript
feature known as
service workers.
And service workers are nice because
they can act as network proxies. So,
normally,
traffic that httpuv would
handle over the network is
instead being handled entirely
client side inside a JavaScript
service worker instead.
And that service worker acts
as our network server, when,
really, it's all
running client side.
With this shim, Shiny apps are
able to run under webR, and,
in particular, they can
run entirely client side.
So the way this works is
that the R Shiny server software
thinks it's talking to httpuv
through its normal R package API.
And at the other side,
we have the Shiny web
client that the user is interacting
with. That thinks it's
talking over the network
to the Shiny server, but
instead that is being
intercepted, as I say, by the
JavaScript service worker.
And then that proxy in the
middle between the Shiny server
and the Shiny client
converts those network
requests, captures them,
converts them, and
sends them to webR.
And webR works with
httpuv to handle those messages.
And the responses
from Shiny, again,
are sent back to the client
at the front end through
that network proxy, through
that service worker. So
through this
package shimming process,
we're able to run
Shiny apps entirely
within the browser,
with both the front-end and
the backend server all running
inside the JavaScript worker.
This is a similar
scheme, by the way,
to how Shinylive
for Python works.
It's not exactly the same
but it is a similar scheme.
And so we're hoping that in
the near future we'll be able to
integrate this kind of
thing directly into Shinylive to
create a Shinylive for R,
which will take the complication
of deploying apps like this
away so that
the general user will be able
to use Shinylive to deploy R
Shiny apps in this way rather
than having to learn the
intricacies of how to use
a JavaScript service worker or
deploy their own
applications in this way.
I do have an example.
So this is a Shiny app
running directly in the web browser.
And you can confirm for
yourself that this really is running
entirely client side,
because that output at the
bottom of the screen is the
output from an R console
running a Shiny server.
So that output is directly
from the Shiny server itself.
And I could disconnect
the network,
I could turn the internet off
and this would still work.
The code for that demo is
available on GitHub. So if you
are a JavaScript developer and you
know about web workers and service workers,
you can read a little more
about how this works in a bit
more detail on that
on that GitHub page.
And it also talks about
some of the requirements for deployment,
particularly when it comes
to setting special HTTP headers
for cross-origin isolation.
And this is something that's
required to get webR to run
in this environment.
So that's everything I wanted
to talk about R packages.
So do visit the REPL app at
the URL at the top of the screen
there and try this out,
load some packages,
and see for yourself which
ones work and which ones don't.
And if you do want to
create your own webR apps,
it's available on
NPM or via CDN.
And the documentation
is at that URL there,
which is well worth looking
through if you are wanting to
integrate webR into your
own web applications.
If you
do any interesting projects with webR
and want to share them, please do
feel free to email me.
And my email is shown
on the screen there.
And I'd love to see
what kind of projects
you create with webR.
Thank you very much. [MUSIC PLAYING]
PLAYING]